alright alright this is a real show I
thought you guys just putting tomato
sauce jars and tricking people just real
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Shia LaBeouf he's
an actor and performance artist with a
pair of brand new films the much buzzed
about peanut butter Falcon which hit
theaters in August and of course the
semi-autobiographical story honey boy
coming to Amazon on November 8th
Shia LaBeouf welcome to the show thank
you for having me are you a hot sauce
guy do you crank it I mean yeah so I'm
half Cajun so yeah I'm a hot sauce guy
but I'm also half Jewish so I'm a little
frightening
[Music]
[Music]
do I put sauce on it or just already
there it's already there let's get it
though right so we're gonna put sauce on
it right there we go all right let's go
okay and you sir boom cheers Cheers
dabbing them all today we'll see how
long we can keep it up the whole way
mm-hmm so as we talked about in your
intro you have a pair of movies this
fall honey boy and peanut butter Falcon
both of which have considerably strong
reviews with some critics calling your
performances career-defining do you see
it that way are these just like the next
projects to you you shall great a dish
dog you're really good at this role
Thank You Shanna I forgot what the
question was I was enamored with you
what did you just ask me do you see
these as career defining films or your
next projects do you do this and where
before we go it doesn't look like I
don't know it just seems so prepared um
a defining um yeah I don't know that I
don't know I um maybe yeah sure yes and
then in a 2008 details profile you said
that you'll read every comment
surrounding the movies even the mean
places ten years later do you still have
that same appetite for reading your own
press I slowed down on there a little
bit I was told to book yeah I care and
especially about peanut butter fowl
because I'm like that were you know
Zac's reading you know so I'm I'm trying
to like keep up with him and he sends
them to me so yeah with peanut butter I
read a lot of them I don't think I'm
gonna do the same thing a honey boy just
too close it's too bright too personal
mhm
I imagine my papa reading though you
always got like contrarians to you know
you always got somebody who just wants
to be slick so and that one will hurt me
I'm a very sensitive dude you'll
remember that one out of the hundred
that are positive yeah exactly so I stay
with
[Music]
with no top okay there you go
we'll probably get more precise with our
pores as we go on
you didn't flow out of necessity for
real okay I'm excited so I know that you
grew up next to Dodger Stadium you bleed
blue and there are few people more
beloved by Dodger diehards than Vin
Scully the late play-by-play announcer
who is known for his poetic broadcasts
so if you'll humor me I want to hit you
with a few classic Scully isms and I'm
just curious I'm just curious how you
process them and whether or not they
ring true to you okay
okay all right it's a mere moment in a
man's life between the all-star game and
the old-timers game yeah what a good
dude I love VIN and I see his face when
you talk he's such a lovable guy such a
teddy bear you got another one sure it's
easier to pick off a fast runner
than to pick off a lazy runner what I
thought the [ __ ] is he talking about I
think because I was confused on this one
too we were talking about it in the car
so maybe it's like if you're bold and
you play fast you're more likely to trip
than if you're like aloof and dumb and
uninterested sure and also stealing is a
touch thing it's definitely not just a
fashion thing right yeah it's a touch
thing as a field thing right this
leggings yeah you got to psychoanalyze a
pitcher from over the shoulder and know
and like get to know him losing feels
worse than winning feels good
definitely VAX bogan what a wing-eating
technique this is not your first I'm not
cute with an IE well how good Cooter's
we okay yeah
[Music]
yeah that was kind of take mine is just
a little sweetie pie sauce well don't
get too ahead of yourself you know cuz I
heard you say about the Trojan horse the
pineapple and then the sneaks in there
well that's what you can do with sweet
and heat I like oh look at you shy buddy
I'll study you too bro I'm in here in
2015 you released a series of short
monologues that were performed on
green-screen which have since birth
thousands of parodies and remixes on
YouTube of this just do it line yeah as
someone who often talks about creativity
in all forms do you have any thoughts
about the second life that your art can
have on the Internet yeah it was made
for that reason I mean that hold those
monologues were made at an MFA show and
Central Saint Martin's and the whole
goal of that thing was to do a their MFA
show online as a way to create memes
that was the intention behind that so
what we did was we asked all the artists
to give us all the work we watched all
the work got really like intimate with
the work and then had them write two or
three sentences and decide whether I was
standing pacing moving or sitting and
then we shot like an hour worth of these
monologues and it was like the intro to
their whole MFA show do you have a
favorite child above me out of the
clapping seems really Pleasant and
joyful and people always throw it in
when it's like a pleasant joyful thing
so maybe the clapping our memes art
definitely yeah anything that moves use
art yeah alright Shia ready to pop the
bottle on the next one yeah this one's
your guys's thing huh they up los
calientes okay okay
[Music]
how can be pretty with the two bones
it's easier to be pretty with the one
bone backbones it gets tricky to be
pretty you got to get the meat in the
middle got a split on okay oh look at
that you just [ __ ] you honey so in 2016
you did have five fingers of death
freestyle on sway in the morning and
were dubbed by sway himself the number
one emcee in Hollywood yeah I mean you
know a lot of actors rap it's the same
brain that does that ad-lib so I imagine
like a bunch of the UCB actors probably
great at freestyling or battling or
battling yeah a bunch of like your
favorite comics are probably really good
at freestyle I bet you like Will Ferrell
is a great freestyle ER right because
it's like the catchphrase or the
punchline or the late drop yeah and the
rhythm is like something you can almost
you can kind of learn that the other
part is the tricky part
like the speed at which you can you know
I think anybody who can ad-lib to
probably stop Tom Hardy freestyle is all
the time you have you rapping all the
time burnt all raps all the time yeah
those guys rap all the time I'm very
tasty nothing very tasty one you guys
personally curated that one we did
congratulations and I was that's very
pretty that's a good one
good job
[Music]
watch how pretty the one bone goes down
take little Keaney bites and I'm Sam
that was an adorable kind of cute little
ghee beer so you've been dubbed the fit
God by Jonah Hill and just last year the
New Yorker described your personal style
is still sexually viable Silverlake dad
crossed with a Chinatown dwelling trust
funded art school kid who's never not up
for doing psychedelics whoa yeah I mean
I wear stuff that's comfortable and that
I'm big into shape but I don't really
care about colors and stuff like that I
like shapes like yeah like a certain
silhouette nothing about shapes like
into the robust collection of t-shirts
that you have which can be anything from
here we have a sports reference er a
vintage TV show I've seen you wear
commemorative merch from a motorcycle
rally in South Dakota before yeah is
that just you pulling something off the
rack cause it looks cool is that the
shape thing or are you drawn to it
because it represents something that
you're into both yeah it matters so to
start with the shape and then if I see
something I'll know that I don't [ __ ]
with and I have to give it up
even if the shapes great so what I want
to do is show you some of our favorite
Shia LaBeouf it picks from over the
years
and I'm sure that in some of them you'll
just be like you know I was going to get
coffee and I just threw something on but
I imagine some of them are a little bit
more important to you so let me just
show you the pictures and you can tell
me what stands out about them now this
time later here you go I think this is
at Sundance oh yeah yeah I was hanging
out with my mom and it was cold outside
and I I remember my publishes mulisch
was like you got to get a jacket bring a
Jackie you know she was talking about
like a funniest fancier jackets so I
found a fancy jacket I could find right
there and then the shoes oh yeah see
that's embarrassing this what I mean is
to see this is these Golden Goose
sneakers yeah okay so I was teaching
this class teach this class down Slauson
and they were like hey you know your
shoes like $500
and and that was the end of those shoes
you know stuff like that where you gotta
be careful you know you can't be you
can't do [ __ ] like that because then
you're making a political decision next
oh yeah there she is and there's just
talking about it right there in there
yeah so a story behind this is Ellen
DeGeneres is like hey you wear these
pants I'll put $500 in it into breast
cancer charity so you call their bluff
on that yeah and shout out melissa is in
the picture
okay looking slick too I may say
speaking of looking slick or we go oh
this is where I got fired from play in
New York that thing yeah and I was just
walking around and snow like Edgar Allan
Poe right there that I have orphans yeah
just sad guy right there's a sad case
like it's not as well ah man but as well
have your box you know like you cleared
out your office oh man and then one more
for you
oh yeah this guy right here [ __ ] this
guy who is he that's you oh man [ __ ] him
oh yeah there's the Kids Choice Awards
I'm trying to figure out I think I was
trying to like probably a girl there I
was like who I look cute for her so let
me wear the stupid beige purple [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh man yeah I didn't really have
much say over that all right yeah
well thus concludes the little walk down
memory lane are you ready to move on
yeah let's go so this is the adobo loco
fire fire Oh Hawaii whoa okay Hawaii is
I'll have a sweet touch to it then huh
[Music]
it's actually the first episode that
we're shooting in season 10 so Shia I'm
doing these for the first time right
along with you hey wow that's cool
that's also an honor that you that you'd
let me do that because I know that Jonas
Brothers opened up your last thing and
and now [ __ ] Jonas Brothers yeah I'm
saying Cheers
thanks for that wish I have some
brothers alright that's a win so when
you talk to a craft brewer about
Budweiser right they might say it's not
for me but they'll have the utmost
respect for the consistency and
technical prowess that goes into making
it does anything about that little beer
story resonate with you when you think
about the Hollywood blockbuster movie
making oh definitely yeah it's people
work hard man not even just at the top
line like all the people below the line
work hard that's all how those are hard
movies to make a hustle for months and
months and years straight I mean like
the best gripping departments are on
those shows best electricians are on
those shows good people and once heard
you call yourself the fakest method
actor good can you unpackage that cuz i
do think it's a term that's maybe thrown
around a little bit too much yeah cuz
I'm not really a method actor I'm more
like a subjection is I'm more like an
escapist I like to run away yeah I like
to fall into something else I like to
that's how I survive really like
escapism I'm Way in escapism a social
wiles of you know have my troubles you
know so it's not really meth it's not
like Stanislavski type method it's like
I'm reading
Stanislavski and going to work and apply
in it you know Stanislavski was a [ __ ]
actor so he wrote like dense paragraphs
about something he wasn't really didn't
really know what the [ __ ] he was talking
about you know I find books like true
and false by David Mamet more helpful
because he was already a confident
writer before he ever wrote that book he
never had to like define himself with
this work or define himself with the
book so he didn't have to make it like
super wordy where Stanislavski who was a
failed actor from a rich family who was
like embarrassed about all that and he
was defining himself on this book
about method so it just winds up super
wordy and I can't really I'm not smart
enough to be able to apply it so I guess
fake method actor is really cuz I
immerse myself in it and that's
traditionally a method thing but I'm not
coming from a Stanislavski place right
and on it goes yeah
the akka me so ghost pepper from bravado
I like the tone you took on that with
that heavy breathing wall was very
breathy we sounded like some kind of
psychic or somebody's now oftentimes we
fact-checked the larger-than-life
mythology surrounding our guests and no
we don't even touch your liquids this
whole time well you're just sitting the
water I think I have this weird habit of
mirroring the guests okay but you
haven't mirrored me at all cuz I'm
almost done with my water so what are
you talking about that was a fake fact
right there nobody has been
larger-than-life mythos eyes more than
Shia LaBeouf's on this wing who what
will do is try to set the record
straight on some popular Hollywood folk
tales surrounding Shia LaBeouf we're
good is it true that at 11 years old you
found your first agent by combing the
Yellow Pages phoning her up and
pretending to be a British manager of a
hot young actor named Shia LaBeouf yeah
that was true she's still my she's still
my girl she still hangs out with my mom
she's still part of the tribe every time
I how like a movie come out she's always
showing up she's still trying to hit on
co-stars she's still she's in the midst
of it man during the filming of fury is
it true that you shaved one of your
teeth down below the gum line and
stopped showering to remain in character
enough to remain in character but sort
of a rally the troops yeah just to sort
of like everybody psyched
yeah where's a rising tide lifts all
ships so I would do some things and
burnt all would do some things and Penny
would do some things and top would do
some things and we would all just kind
of try to keep everybody involved did
they have to relocate you to another
bed-and-breakfast because of the whole
no shower
there was another reason they had to
relocate me to another bad breakfast so
there was like they were having a some
kind of some fancy meeting at one of our
hotels and they had all this chicken me
and Bernthal were sitting on this couch
one day and we were hungry and burnt I
was like I'll don't worry what eat when
we get there and I just figured nah [ __ ]
it we're just gonna get this chicken so
I beelined it for the chicken he saw the
security coming he just like ducked out
on the mission yeah
lefty hanging yeah and he really did
yeah so I grabbed a couple chickens and
then walked out and as I'm walking out
Security's like what do you think you're
doing and I turn around I was like well
I'm part of this meeting I was getting
my chicken everybody's getting shaking
and relax and he's like you know this is
like the Bilderberg meeting you know
what the Bilderberg meeting is that's
like the billionaire sort of like the
Illuminati make in the world turned me
right so like in the city manatees don't
chicken in this same meeting I'm
stealing chicken from the Bilderberg
meeting I just thought it was like
people talking about whatever I'm never
really talking about running the whole
world and like the Koch brothers are in
there George Soros just like a wild
group of people and like I'm just
walking around with chicken in my hand
you know so his [ __ ] ridiculous but
yeah they somebody in the meeting was
like and then they kicked me out when
Kanye West raided your closet did he
take your Indiana Jones hat I gave him
the hat yeah I'm the Indiana Jones he
was like wow which this was in a glass
box and he's like what is this I was
like try it on and it didn't fit at all
and he had it on like a yarmulke and I
was like that's kind of giro like
wearing a hat like a yarmulkes kind of
geez that you think so I was like in a
take it never really worried but he has
it yeah
are the rumors of you knocking out Tom
Hardy on the set of lawless overstated
yeah it's a bunch of [ __ ] we used to
wrestle all the time and he was just
gives a big [ __ ] person especially
then he's getting ready for Bain
one time yeah so my girlfriend at the
time was over at my house we're on his
balcony we saw him and his trainer come
back from the gym and we used to [ __ ]
with each other all the time but it just
so happened that this one week my
girlfriend was in town
and he runs into the room but the girl I
was with at the time was terrified and
she's like aah and she covered up she
ran into the kitchen he picked me up and
I didn't have nothing on so now I'm
naked on his shoulder were in the
hallway
we're wrestling around I'm like peanut
peanuts filming at all I'm like Pino you
can't be filling this [ __ ] and we were
like rest and then I got upset about it
because he got the better of me but I'm
in some weird twisty naked position like
my shits over here and the shits over
here I'm like uh don't we wanted like
inching over the stairs where the stairs
were and he fell down the stairs you
know I don't hurt in his back so for the
rest of the shoot he told everybody I
knocked him out but that wasn't the case
we were having some weird like a cutie
wrestling match okay bang all right okay
this is a little crazy mm-hmm washer you
were very conservative with universe got
some kind of sweet but Oh is it frozen
that's a Trojan one you can see why I
was a little conservative a little
surgical with my poor yeah yeah it's hot
as [ __ ] right
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah all right this is a real show I
thought you got you to put tomato sauce
on these jars and tricking people it's
real ladies and gentlemen it's real so
as I understand it you began performing
that stand-up comedy clubs when you're
10 years old describing your styles of
50 year old mouth on a ten year old boy
how did crowds at the ice house and the
baked potato how did they react to a
young kid up there like do you think
they gave you more leeway because they
were like look at this cute kid chasing
his comedy dreams or did they still
heckle you the same way well my dad was
in the Mongols so every time I would go
up there'd be a bunch of bikers in the
bar and they laughed the loudest and
then four bunch of bikers are laughing
then everyone's laughing you know like
if you got like 16 bikers back here
laughing because he's like the family
kid and everybody else starts laughing I
never got taunted on stage I was
squatting all in too deep yeah I was
squatted people when I was very young I
used to get up there with a bowl cut and
overalls see look now you're going yeah
there you are whoa buddy that was an
extreme thing that we did it's [ __ ]
hotter than a oh my goodness that's big
room hot right there buddy I'm gonna
switch to the milk cuz I can't even I
almost can't see you anymore Sam you
look underwater right now you like
wearing a submarine playing playing
around so my dad would always be like
all right that's enough that he would do
is you do his loud laugh in his cloud I
forgot what the [ __ ] mean talking
about
[Music]
are you still on this pop the top okay
yeah come on we can't do it this on the
vacation side they get over here you're
right yeah I'm about to have tears
streaming down my face for real I
already do
can you see that maybe zoom in I'm about
to start crying I'm feeling like I'm on
touched by an angel right now look oh
there goes Billy Diller Reese I look so
sad right now don't I look so sad
don't I look sad
I'm I'm buying it out there damned yeah
do you have another get Rosen we just
break into tears on this show it's
happened before but not quite with that
with that kind of depth yeah yeah I look
like I really knit with him so I was
really moved by that you okay mm-hmm all
right so yes burn after eating all right
load up oh man maybe there's a trick I
should learn about this was is way
easier than like spending all night in a
room is he some hot sauce action
cheers cheers Cheers I your hands
shaking a little bit
well we're going through some things
over here you know all right let's get
it you've been a great chauffeur thank
you
[Music]
see one way of doing it cute is you
could bite in the middle and push the
middle chicken in and some even took the
middle by you a little push a little key
bit cuter than doing the whole [ __ ]
around will caught the shiet push yeah
yeah no so I look so sad right now do I
look like you just beat me up so at the
time of this interview it's been almost
a year to the day since you guys open
the Slauson rec theatre company
experimental theater in downtown LA yeah
after one year what are you most proud
of what's been the biggest challenge
well four of my kids got on some Netflix
shows which is awesome
I got no cheer look at how kraut Lou
[Music]
from the other eye you know not all
actors can do now I'm serious
yes so for my kids got on some some
Netflix shows and we got performances
tonight actually just the fact that
we've been able to get more shows you
know not just like home turf stuff but
the fact that careful are out of your
eyes okay
in fact that other people have been able
to like invite us into their thing too
has been nice like other artists or like
co-signing us that's really nice and we
built like a little family so everybody
loves each other we like hanging out on
the weekends you got a little bit of hot
sauce in your beer right there
I'm scared to touch anything oh you
probably [ __ ] yourself doing this huh
why so many times I've been you know in
different ways even like you know it'll
burn on your skin the eye is the worst
so sometimes I just I just take it on
all right like you you got some like
milk going on yeah and we're uh we're in
the stash a little bit go over your
lower stash southern southern stash just
sleep all right dude
okay all right Shia there's the main one
right here is it we're on to the last
stop okay
top is popped xxx is it so this is the
last dab xxx okay but we've been less
dab in this whole show all the way
through this will go down in history
okay how you feeling after this feel
pretty good I mean I look sad as [ __ ]
but inside I'm feeling really good comes
out dick it's a big boy
it looks like doodoo all right we make
this one do all right
[Music]
Shaya
here we are on the last stop of our
spicy winged journey dab in every wing
along the way but one thing we've missed
is your love of hot dogs you had this
great quote in a 2007 Vanity Fair
profile where you said I can't tell you
how many hot dogs I've eaten in my life
we had these inventive ways of making
them it looked like Wolfgang Puck but it
was just two hot dogs yeah
can you expound on that that's a great
quote like do you remember some of the
more creative ways that you've eaten hot
dogs in your life is it gonna sound like
the saddest hot dog story cuz I look I'm
sure but yeah oh man I swallowed that
one in the weird Oh No so uh yeah what I
used to do is I used to take hot dogs
raw and then I cut them like small
slices like that but only half way down
then I fry them they make me little
circles little hotdog circles or
sometimes I would take a hot dog and go
like this little corkscrew
a little corkscrew hot dog and then put
it on the fryer and it would braid you
can make like a little hot dog braid is
that tear from hot sauce are you just on
ready now now I'm reflecting now I'm
reflecting on these special dogs I used
to make all right well you heard it from
Shia LaBeouf which means that it's the
truth and look at you Shia a changed man
baptized by hot sauce all the way down
ten wings I had a blast so I hope a
guest does not suggest that we do that
again now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you Shia
LaBeouf this camera this camera this
camera the people know what you have
going on in your life I'm just trying to
just try and get do this right now
I
I probably look so sad when I yeah what
I got going on in my life I'm happy to
be on the show it's nice to meet all of
you and it was a pleasure yeah that's
what's going on in my life right now
actively I just met you I'm a big fan
thanks for letting me be here well thank
you shy I'm a big fan as well can't wait
to watch careful there get the spice off
role but is I hope it didn't get in you
know this guy what the [ __ ]
what is up spice lards camera guy bill
here I know we've retired the laptop
this season and you all miss me but I
want you to know that I'm still hard at
work behind the camera if you like
today's episode it would mean a lot to
me and the rest of the hot ones crew to
give us a little like or a little
subscribe it would really mean a lot
this camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
you